that's what we should be doing we should
be chugging champagne we should be
wearing diamonds collecting albino
pythons I'm over here I'm holding on to
the poop side of this scrubber [ __ ] the
bay even his dog oil Puma has a hundred
thousand followers sweep the hotel we
are our lockdown boss party's over
I think we should turn ourselves in
what's with the pockets I'm showing them
I'm unarmed set off we can take them an
idea
my plan work plane didn't work you got
me 300 kicked in the chest I'm gonna go
put on pants
you are for this we take their guns and
free the hostages
right
we're here to collect a toll from Bay
awadhi ain't touching my stacks breath
this lady just [ __ ] her pants I did I
did not [ __ ] my pants are you calling me
a liar no want someone did [ __ ] their
pants and I'm not gonna say who
[Applause]
are you ready to be Tom Brady
do you think Tom Brady is in the Brady
Bunch
it's the dad right oh no use it well you
didn't bring me along to look like the
black nerd from die hard cuz I don't
[Music]
you
you